[Music]
thank you
coming up on FYI adventure and
businessman Sir Richard Branson serves
us why dyslexia has nothing to be
ashamed of I think that dyslexic people
have think differently than other people
and because we have difficulties with
some things we actually exceed at the
things that we are good at
[Music]
is great for saving money but not so
great for saving the planet
[Music]
FYI it's our mission to investigate
anything that's going on in the world
right now let's start with an update on
our recent investigation into kitsu Vape
we discovered that despite warnings that
alleged cigarettes could be bad for your
health and addictive a rising number of
kids are vaping and they are being sold
rates legally now a new survey seems to
show an increasing number of children
and teens are trying out vaping and are
still able to buy them even though they
should only be sold to over 18s the
survey by the organization Ash spoke to
nearly 3000 11 to 17 year olds
it found that children trying vaping has
gone up by half in the last year from
7.7 to 11.6 percent
Corner shops are still the most common
place to get a hold of Vapes even though
it's legal to sell them to under 18s the
number of children smoking Vapes has
also risen to 7.6 percent
that may not sound that many but it
could mean hundreds of thousands of
people our age are vaping the Prime
Minister watched our investigation and
in an exclusive interview with me and
Braden he promised to crack down on
shops that sell Vapes to kids we are
having a Crackdown Squad we put millions
of pounds behind it and they're going to
go and make sure all the rules are
enforced you know no one should be
vaping under 18. it's illegal to sell
Vapes to to Children the adverts for
these things are designed to appeal to
kids you know with the colors they use
the characters they use that's not right
the flavors this is all things that
shouldn't be happening you can see more
of that interview and our FYI
investigation into kitsu Vape on Sky
Kids On Demand on our webpage
some more stories that got our attention
this is the damage caused by a storm
known as a cyclone which hit Bangladesh
and Myanmar the speed of the women's up
to 130 miles per hour
tens of thousands of people reach 30
buildings and shelters
this is the biggest Cyclone to hit the
two countries in 10 years yeah and check
this out Bangladesh has one of the
world's largest refugee camps it's home
to over a million rohingya Muslims who
fled violent attacks in neighboring
Myanmar The Authorities say the refugees
were evacuated from the camps which is
made up of tents and Shacks now the
focus is to get food and sheltered to
those who need it and Charities have
launched an appeal for aid while the
Ukrainian President Vladimir silensky
has also been asking for help as Russia
continues to attack his country here he
is just a few days ago in the UK talking
to our prime minister
so what is he asking the Prime Minister
for well the president has been touring
around Europe meeting world leaders he's
been asking for more money to support
Ukrainian families and fighter jets
missiles tanks bullets you name it and
he's getting that support right yes I
know he thanked the UK and other
countries for their support the UK
sending him fight to Jets and attack
drones but he says more help is still
needed you did a lot to you your
government and His Majesty the king and
of course your people your Society where
we're thankful from all our hearts from
ukrainians from our soldiers we are
thankful not long after they left the UK
Russia attacked Cave of the heaviest
bombing of the city since the invasion
began
well I've got some happy news not if
you're a Manchester United fan though
this is the Chelsea women's team lifting
the FA Cup for a third time in a row
making history there as they beat
Manchester United in one nil and we've
been on the lookout for some fake news
so there are posts on social media
warning us to look out for the Asian
Hornet quick online search and you can
see they look like a wasp but much
bigger
the Warriors that they attack honeybees
and we really need them because they
help fruit and vegetables grow by flying
around and pollinating plants but
Eurasian Hornets really invading the UK
from abroad well there have been
reported sightings in Kent and
Northumberland fake or facts we'll let
you know later
[Music]
so this is Sir Richard Branson he's one
of the most successful and richest
entrepreneurs in the UK
and this is George an FYI News Club
member from Woodlands primary school and
they both have something in common they
have dyslexia a learning difficulty that
affects lots of people
if someone has dyslexia they can find it
difficult to read write or spell but
research also shows that they can be
talented and creative in different types
of areas Richard Branson said that his
dyslexia actually helped him to become
so successful he invited George to
interview him about his campaign to get
teachers to see dyslexia as an advantage
not a disadvantage
hello thank you for coming to talk to me
today hi George good good to meet you
you call dyslexia your superpower what
do you mean by that I think that
dyslexic people think differently than
other people and they're generally more
creative and because we have
difficulties with some things we
actually exceed at the things that we
are good at and you'll find that
throughout life we will exceed at things
that other other kids cannot exceed at
your new campaign what are you trying to
achieve with that there's a wonderful
organization called made by dyslexia and
they have created a program for
companies and schools to help them in
teaching and training people who are
dyslexic I was dyslexia affected you as
an adult I suspect if I wasn't dyslexia
I wouldn't be so inquisitive I wouldn't
want to be learning all the time from
starting a student magazine to wanting
to build a record company to start an
airline you know even ultimately to
start a space company and it's also been
good in that it's taught me to to get a
great team of people around me and to
look for the best in people and that's I
think it's really important in life is
always look for the best in the people
around you and you'll you'll achieve
Lots did you feel like
I feel like when you were younger the
word dyslexia didn't exist I don't think
when I was young and therefore I didn't
get any support but today it's great
that you know dyslexia is accepted and
and schools give extra time to to help
people who are dyslexic did you imagine
you'd be as successful today if you
weren't dyslexic I'm absolutely certain
that I owe a lot of My Success to being
dyslexic and wanting to try to prove
something to myself and and prove
something to people around me and it's
been a lot of fun and I'm sure that
you're going to have a lot of fun in the
years to come
um maybe if we're lucky working with a
virgin one day
um you're a dyslexic thinker and you
should be proud of it so best of luck to
you thank you for coming to talk to me
thanks George
nice one George so if your school hasn't
set up an FYI News Club then you could
be missing out members get the chance to
report and have their say here on FYI
just like George plus you get lots of
resources for your Club so you can
discuss and learn more about the big
stories just get your teacher to head to
our webpage for more details
foreign
to be seeing more and more bees right
wind farms Britain wind farms have
generated more electricity in the first
three months of this year than gas-fired
power stations lots of us the government
has promised to get more win and solar
panel Farms up and running while experts
warn we rely too much in gas and coal to
generate electricity fossil fuels that
release gases into the atmosphere that
lead to climate change did you know
that's not just fossil fuels that's bad
for the environment it's the clothes you
wear too don't get it neither did we
Maya has been investigating
[Music]
let's be honest we all love to look our
best and we all have our own different
types of style and this definitely isn't
mine
that's more like it
but if you ever stopped and thought
about what you wear and what damage it
can be causing to the environment
a few facts I found out in the UK we buy
around 60 billion pounds worth of
clothes every year and that's more than
any other country in Europe
according to a recent survey the average
person owns 76 items of clothing but
throws away about six items every month
and right now less than one percent of
the material we check out is recycled
into new garments
let's face it we can't escape adverts
for fashion and deals from clothes shops
online but the main reason we buy so
many clothes has got to be the
incredibly low prices
take a look at this t-shirt for example
and guess how much I paid for it was it
20 pounds 10 pounds or two pounds well
the answer is
two pounds
it sounds like a bargain and fast
fashion as it's often called does help
to make clothes affordable for everyone
but you should be really careful when
clothes are this cheap as it can mean
they're of poor quality and they won't
last long
the best advice is to always check out
how your clothes have been made
to find out more about this I'm gonna
ask for some help and I know just the
person
Izzy Manuel is an expert on sustainable
fashion hi Izzy thanks for talking to me
thank you so much for having me it's
such a pleasure so we all love a good
deal right but should we be wary of
things like my two pound t-shirt
I think when it comes to products that
are that cheap we have to think about
how they're made and who they're made by
so some clothing stores are sustainable
and are ethical but sadly not all of
them are and when something is that
cheap often the government workers are
the ones that have to pay for that which
means that they're the ones that are
working unethical conditions there may
not being paid a living wage and
actually there's an estimation that only
two percent of garment workers worldwide
actually paid living wages and what
about the cost to the environment of
fast fashion is that a problem I think
this is something that's not really
talked about that often but fast fashion
is actually so detrimental to the
environment so for example for a single
pair of jeans it actually requires 10
000 liters of water to make them which
is equivalent to 125 full bathtubs worth
of water and I think when you think
about the chemicals involved in
processing of garments whether that's
dying washing cleaning all of that adds
up and often this water and this toxic
waste ends up in rivers which is
obviously really unsustainable
so what can we do about all of this well
one obvious solution is to just buy
fewer clothes it saves you money and it
helps the environment the truth is that
too many of us are buying new outfits
knowing that we'll probably only wear
them a few times before we throw them
away
but does ditching fast fashion mean
you're going to look a bit rubbish
absolutely not for example I am wearing
a full second-hand outfit today and
personally I feel like I look alright
just because you don't buy fast fashion
anymore doesn't mean that you don't have
to look cool doesn't mean you won't look
trendy and there are so many ways around
that for example you can swap with your
friends you can buy second hand you can
go to charity shops all these things can
still create a wardrobe that you love
that isn't as impactful in the
environment one other top tip is that
when you put your clothes in the washing
machine try to use a lower temperature
it helps your clothes to last longer and
reduces the amount of microplastics that
are released from Fabrics like polyester
or nylon Izzy what else can we do to
help tackle the problem I think one of
the things that we could definitely do
more is actually learn to repair our
clothes do some more alterations for
example do you actually know how to use
a sewing kit it's actually the best
thing ever and it's a great way to
maintain our clothes to fix more holes
and it means it keeps up in our
wardrobes for longer thank you Izzy
that's brilliant advice
thank you so much for having me and I
hope it was helpful
so what have I learned well it is
possible to look great without it having
to cost the Earth
and instead of fast fashion maybe the
answer is to get fashion that lasts
foreign
so is this story about Asian Hornets
invading the UK true
it is indeed facts but only a few have
been spotted
the big concern is that these large was
like bugs prey on honeybees which help
plants that produce food to grow
if you see one the advice is to keep
away as they will sting if they feel
threatened and report your sights into
the local authorities
[Music]
we're always after your stories here on
FYI so if you have something that you
want to report on get in touch via our
webpage just like Sophia did she's a
rising star in a very difficult sport
she wanted to tell you more about
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu
[Music]
this is Brazilian Jiu Jitsu a martial
arts that I've been learning since I was
five years old the idea is to overcome
your opponent using particular
self-defense moves
it's all about technique and we are not
hurting each other in any way you have
to be trained properly to do this only
with an adult professional watching over
you I've been doing Jiu Jitsu for six
years and I've won over 50 competitions
I'm an ibjj F British and European
Champion I've been ranked number one
female in the UK by the All-Stars
one of my goals is to go to less
developed countries to go teach young
kids because when I was little I used to
always be in a shell and be very shy but
since I started Brazilian Jiu Jitsu I
became more confident
Brazilian Jiu Jitsu feels the closest
way of having superpowers
so that's what I think other young kids
should do it to come out of their shell
nice report Sophia yeah those are some
moves well that's all we've got for you
this time make sure to check out all of
our videos with lots more info and your
stories see you next time bye
foreign
[Music]